uh plans for an emergency multi-million
pound loan to civil greens struggling
arcadia group have reportedly
fallen through fifteen thousand jobs are
at risk as big names like topshop
dorothy perkins and burton
are said to be on the brink of collapse
let's turn to our business presenter ian
king
who's in the uh city studio ian welcome
to you
is this increasingly looking like where
the arcadia story ends do you think
i think so colin that is certainly very
much the uh speculation that
the administrators are going to get
called in at some point uh later
today now we heard over the weekend of
course uh as our colleague mark kleinman
reported that mike ashley
owner of uh sports director and the
house of fraser
he has reportedly offered to make a loan
of some 50 million pounds
to arcadia on an unsecured basis
critically and that
of course follows uh on reports from uh
friday that uh
arcadia was seeking an emergency uh cash
flow uh
a cash injection of 30 million pounds to
uh tied it through
this period now mike ashley's
frasers group has confirmed that to the
stock market this morning
but it's conditional of course on uh sir
philip green opening his books opening
the arcadia books
to mike ashley and i think that's rather
unlikely to happen a lot of people in
the market
who say that this is a bit of trolling
uh by mike ashley of
philip green the two have a a friendly
rivalry
well it's not so friendly anymore uh in
recent years
they did cooperate very closely at one
point in time they they got on and would
socialize from time to time
but uh more recently uh mike ashley uh
was trying to get hold of
uh get uh control of uh debenhams the
department store chain uh which
incidentally uh five percent of his
revenues come
from uh arcadia concessions he thinks
that philip green was uh interfering on
that to uh
scupper his uh takeover of that business
in the background so this may be
a bit of payback as far as mike ashley's
concern but as i say we're expecting
administrators to be called in today
not only thirteen thousand employees and
ten thousand members of the pension fund
potentially uh at risk of losing out
here there are also creditors who own
tens of millions of pounds
by arcadia and they may well lose out
too
ian thanks very much